- Dragging my ass out here on Christmas.
- [Kelce, Johnson singing:] Jawn we now our game day apparel!
The disrespect.
- Buddy! We gotta take an
MVP photo!
Go put on your jersey.
- Let's make this quick. I'm on a minutes restriction...
unless I decide I'm not.
- Whoa, fellas, I can't let-
Classic... war on Christmas.
- [into walkie:] We’re in.
- What the hell was that?
- Christmas is a basketball holiday.
And for 17 years it's been a LeBron holiday.
And we're gonna make sure it stays that way.
- I just tried my first gingerbread
cookie person.
America, man.
- No, I'm only here for work.
- Young king, are you cryin’?
- YOUSE gotta problem?! ‘Cuz Christmas is an emotional time of year.
- Hmm, hmm. That’s not how coaches speak to players in MY league.
- Lamar versus everybody.
Just like old times.
- KD, cut the feed. Football's going off the air...
- Hang on.
Some kid online is arguing with me about VORP.
- [AD:] What's the matter?
You don’t run anymore?
AH, MY LEG!
- Really?
- AHHHHH!!
- That's the WORST fall I've ever seen.
- Please, step back. You're offside.
- OH, NOW YOU TELL ME.
- Christmas is mine.
You can have January.
- Do it, Lamar!
They’re basketball players. They’re cooler than you!
- Yippee-Ki-Yay, Justin Tucker!
Happy trails, Bron.
- Lamar!
- I knew you were gonna do thattttt...
- Now let's celebrate Christmas
the right way:
Ignoring our families by alternating
between football and basketball.
- Do you really think you have a chance against us, Mr. Cowboy?
- Cowboy?
I was always kinda partial to the Ravens.
- Oh, really? I'm a big Browns fan this week.